انسحبت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من بلده
قطن شمال غربي القدس المحتله بعد اقتحام
دام نحو اربع ساعات وافاد رئيس المجلس
البلدي ضياء الفقيه في اتصال هاتفي مع
الجزيره بان قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت البلده
واغلقت الطرق المؤديه اليها وانتشرت في
احيائها واطلقت قنابل الصوت والغاز المسيل
للدموع صوب المواطنين اضاف الفقيه ان قوات
الاحتلال اعتقلت سته مواطنين على الاقل
بينما اخضعت اخرين للتحقيق الميداني واكد
ان جنود الاحتلال دهم عددا من منازل
المواطنين
ودمروا محتوياتها من ناحيتها قال نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني ان الاحتلال اعتقل اكثر
من
4000 و900 فلسطيني في الضفه منذ بدايه
الحرب على
غزه كما تداولت منصات محليه مشاهد
لمواجهات بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال في مخيم شعفاط بالقدس
المحتله واقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ايضا قريه قوصين غرب مدينه نابلس في شمال
الضفه
الغربيه في غضون ذلك اظهرت مشاهد بثتها
منصات محليه تمركز قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي داخل قريه برطعه شمال غربي
الضفه الغربيه بعد اقتحامها خلال ساعات
الفجر
الى ذلك وثقت مشاهد بثها ناشطون لحظات
اعتقال قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عددا من
الفلسطينيين من داخل احد المنازل في بلده
بيت ايبا غربيه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه بعد
اقتحام استمر
لساعات